la tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono fatti j
ci siamo sulle chivu che lakeview kevin
ho fatto pronunciato un titolo che non
so voglio una medaglia solo per hanno
fatto era una demo per diventare suscito
gioco ufficiale mettiamola così e voglio
vedere che cazzo quello che avevo
giocato secoli fa era strano ma
veramente saranno adesso c'è un nick a
chi sono come sono e perché sono ragazzi
che succede un soldato usa un tizio ho
preso il tizio com è una tipologia di
taxi nuova tecnologica sono 500 euro
ogni due metri con ho capito dove sta
dal giorno anche questo possibile honda
racing si sa perché ma qual è il senso
bisogna poi si guarda dentro perfetto
ragazzi cosa sta succedendo lakeview
kevin 3 bella signora c'è un uomo lì e
lo vendo a 5 euro lo vuole che cosa mi è
servita attiva sta roba aiutato scusa
zia non volere va beh ma qual è il senso
strike ho fatto strike giorno cesso
pulito e mio grazie è posso darlo sì ma
si cazzi zio e mangiato pesante è la
madonna che cazzo è una cagata per tutta
la settimana però non ci sto capendo una
ceppa di minchia voglio dire il cazzo è
successo ragazzi non ho capito cosa è
successo ma mi è saltata la faccia
e morto è morto è vabbè c'è un coso in
acqua che uccide le persone che erika ma
spiegatemi street e ho spaccato o non ho
più una gamba il pezzo la mia gamba
terre bellissimo sono traguardi della
vita questi ho preso la mia gamba e sono
felice fatemi andare avanti un attimo
perché sta pisciando sangue nome
il cazzo sei tu più atipici in faccia al
sangue tipici faccia da via via c'è un
tizio con un'ascia dov'è il motore ho
lasciato il motorino credo ne è andato
dall'altra parte ha prestato il vomito
cioè il vomito sotto i piedi
meraviglioso ragazzi ti lancio un pacco
regalo sono giù sono giu luca luca non
mi raggiunge su cazzu cazzu cazzu caso
guarda che so più veloce di te so più
veloce di te pur in acqua [ __ ] chi
dovrebbe essere quella che ti lancio il
mio compagno è cosa che mi ha ucciso
prima in a poi ho paura andare in acqua
ragazzo nullo già fai schifo mettiti
pure nudo non è che cazzo no mourinho
per center in avanti
insomma tu il tuo cane i tuoi amici
siete morti fine del gioco ma l'afa cosa
c'è l'obiettivo è quello di sopravvivere
la radio anche il campus a lanciare
anche il cane ma ovvio richiesta c'è
paga adesso non fossi in casa
ma [ __ ] come faccia entrare entro
[ __ ] ti lanci un cane ti lancio
lancia canepa hai paura
hai paura del cane non ho paura lezione
è morta è morta con le morta era svetta
vini come vieni come vico ti porto io
ragazzi dovesse come chiasso la metti in
salvo spiegatemelo [ __ ] eh va beh
no non ci credo non ci sto chiedendo non
ci fosse ragazza mi ha preso perché sono
caduto tre volte giochiamo lascia lascia
lascia sì l'ho presa come manna o
katsunori persa ma [ __ ] come cosa
villaggio addosso ad action così fatta
questo cos'è eva l'oasi [ __ ] non ci
posso mai credere che dai come fa come
cazzo fate uccidermi ai 300 all'ora col
motorino [ __ ] anonimi sono
investito la sosta dai dai dai ma dai su
chi ha meno si porta brutta trovava ieri
di sviare la sicurezza ma come ma come
non ne fossi via dentro veloce cazzo
lancio quest'uomo bilancio discutiamone
viste come fa
no no no adesso continuerò così per il
resto della mia vita io sono ancora vivo
non no [ __ ] eva bella è l'unico modo
per spostare dei personaggi e prenderli
in braccio praticamente ecco allora
questo è nascosto non ci troverà mai qua
dentro ragazzi non ci posso credere
cielo o l'estintore
marcolin filone il culo giunta volo
prendi qualcuno è riuscita ad uccidermi
con l'istinto l'avevo preso io mi è
rimasto un personaggio e non mi ha visto
o il sudore freddo come gli occhi la
[Musica]
è questo chi cazzo è ma è la madonna no
no no no no no no no [ __ ]
[ __ ] cagare un cazzo questo conte
tagliati baffi stavolta serio ma serio
proprio la radio la distratto prima non
so come non ho capito però vabbè quindi
accendiamo la radio
scendi sta cazzo di radio accendi la
noah c'è cosa cazzo fai alza lo alzano
dio mio santo che è bello che sei nero è
passato il cane è passato il cane allora
io adesso sto per fare una cosa che se
riesco voglio gli applausi e le medaglie
ok se io metto st radio qua e lui si
spaventa rimane qua sotto e quello
schiaccio no se funziona sto piano non
so se funziona ma ci provo
posso denudare anche questa tizia fatica
obiettivo sale detta di fa era perché
sono gnocca quindi posso proprio luridi
sono un [ __ ] c'è verso
eccolo veloce sentono fattore gap dove
obama
eccola l'epicità che è vivo
come fa essere ancora non è possibile
come fa ad essere ancora vivo no ai cup
su rai storia la musica non fai così non
si ferma però nè che posso stare così
tutto il tempo regga che cazzo
no è via via via via via via veloce no
no ti prende lascia lo sapevo via via
via [ __ ] morte ma lasciamo morire
ragazzi siamo in acqua è una donna che
schifo
alla fine quello che sta meglio e lui
che annuncia la gamba no mi bpv veloce
bra veloce bravo bravo veloce chat 3g la
prendi qualcosa e due palle meno ma
vicini
[Musica]
prendi lo prendi no no dall'aspetto
tasto dai cazzo
no dai ragazzi serve una [ __ ] arma
sono morto morto sono nostro centro sono
morto sono morto morto morto
d'anna vacca anche la stella di salverà
perché richiesti nostro riuscito a
vincere non è possibile adesso ha in
questo momento preparo sempre parola min
l'assetto perfetto con questo qua dovrei
riuscire a ucciderlo a tutti gli effetti
se non muore così ragazzi non muore più
ve lo dico prima di tutto passa arriva
la radio si ferma lo faccio cadere
facendo questa merda poiché faccio
cadere sta merda passo con la tizia al
motorino e lo investo dopo che lo
investo passo la pizza collage a lido
lasciata dopo lasciata passo al tizio
che li dal ha rastrellato sto casino
devo vincere tutto me frega niente è
solo passa appena passa ho vinto
cazzo ci siamo ragazzi veloce allora è
piano piano piano piano mi chiami aiuto
ok ci siamo come ci siamo ragazzi ci
siamo perfetto perfetto fermati mamma
un'andata carica fan non hanno chiuso
peccato presto preso preso adesso di
nuovo dargli fuoco
beep beep beep beep passo però argento
votarli fuoco erano nell'imposizione
dove è morto è mar basta madonna al sito
fuoco uguale anche se non ci sei non
fuoco perché c'è un altro ancora che
passa col coltello quel lurido testa di
merda ragazzi non è morgan i sei core
amica ti do fuoco vieni vieni
[Musica]
deve passare di qua te passa di qua e là
c'è sì lo so bene
adesso non muore adesso mica ma devi
bruciare vivo tre volte è morto reale
adesso è morto però se non ci sapete
come ha fatto a sopravvivere
oh mio dio che bello che sei sempre bene
adesso sai va bene e seriamente non è
morto non muore mai dove è possibile
come fare se uccidete la qualcuno
investa fate qualcosa
c'è un fucile ma dona molto peggio chi
cazzo è questo ma no ma no ma no ma no
no no no no mi girano i [ __ ] girano
i [ __ ]
no no no no sono circondato mi siedo è
non è bastato sedersi vero non mi potete
picchiare voi 291 rimasto solo così
ragazzi non è non si sto credendo sono
rimasto solo con questa c'è uno col
coltello e cioè quello che ancora vivo
che striscia carbonizzato spiegatemi
come come si spara questa stronzata
come facciamo noi li [ __ ] e
scarico è fottutamente scarico
[Musica]
lancio il cane è morto si è morto col
cane è bastava il cane ditelo prima
porca vacca cani sono armi letali
ricordate la sa cosa che è importante
che è successo se lo spinge si giù col
mio amico qui no no no non mi fido nomi
dicono mi fido sono mai visto ma vista
non ha visto non malissimo visto mi
nascondo mi nascondo mi nascondo a cosa
riesco a spingerlo forte i rei di no a
chi morisse la famiglia tua sorella
baffute barbuta ci sono il sito per metà
perché il primo è morto è già qualcosa
che sei riuscito a ucciderne uno e va
bene così e quindi ragazzi conclude
episodio net ne farò sicuramente un
altro perché è bellissimo fa è
leggermente girare i [ __ ] pre
veramente figo quindi ragazzi conclude
episodio ci sono altri scenari di sicuro
perché questo tipo oltre i ragazzi
servizio è piaciuto è tassato momento mi
piace per ogni mi piace che mettete una
passata di motorino sopra quello stronzo
di prima che è rimasto carbonizzato
solisti e ragazzi